I’ve always enjoyed the MCU, but I think Ant-Man
Quantumania is the straw to break marvel’s back.
Phase 4 was definitely rocky with movies like
Eternals, Black Widow, Thor: Love and Thunder,
and Doctor Strange, but at least those movies
were all relatively self-contained and were
set with the tasks of telling an in-between
story from the infinity saga to the multiverse
saga. Marvel was starting to tear under the
sheer quantity they were outputting during
phase 4 and now that Ant-Man Quantumania
was supposed to be the front runner that
rocks everyone leading into phase 5 and it
being disappointing is upsetting. Initially,
I wasn’t going to do this review, but
I got a little fired up on Letterboxd,
so I’ll structure this video in a similar
way and won’t make it overly long.
First, let’s go into the writing. Now I’m going
to be honest with you guys, I think this is one
of the worst MCU scripts that has been put to the
screen so far. Which sucks because I had hope for
Jeff Loveness. Given that he wrote some great
episodes for Rick and Morty. The usual marvel
inclusion of humor rarely works once again and
detracts from the big dramatic requirement the
movie needs given the mass stakes. One main reason
it doesn't work here in comparison to other marvel
movies is because some scenes are solely based on
comedy like the Glup Shitto hole scene that was
just odd. Instead of the humor being reserved for
fast quips it takes a focus a lot of the time and
it hurts entire scenes. Since this isn’t a quick
small-stakes adventure like the first two ant-man
movies, I think this big blend of humor doesn’t
mix as well. Because quipping is fine every now
and then, but scenes that should have more of a
dramatic focus don’t because of the humor. The
dialogue also feels really lazy like just throwing
quantum in front of things like the prior movies,
Michael Douglas saying ANTS in every other
sentence which only made me think of this promo,
and no real sense of wit in any moment. The
movie was never able to get me to care about
the character’s talking to each other and a major
aspect that relies on this was Cassie and Scott’s
relationship. It feels really tacked on for this
movie and the creators don’t do enough to make you
care about their relationship. Considering that
the crux of the movie depends on their strong
bond, some dramatic beats fall short because
of this lack of connection between them. Also,
a lot of the sci-fi elements are overly
goofy like the controls for an alien ship
having condom joysticks. The writing feels
like whatever random wacky shit the writer
wants to throw on screen instead of having any
semblance of coherency. I just constantly felt
detached from this world because it flat doesn’t
make sense when the writer makes no attempt at
breathing logic into this world. Now having
wacky sci-fi concepts is fine, but when you
unload dozens of random elements in every scene
that aren’t complimentary, then it starts to
feel like an AI is generating the world for you.
Then the plot is not original enough and for how
much time it galavants around pretending to be
Star Wars and you wish it was a movie primarily
about Kang. Because when he's around the movie
quickly becomes significantly better. That's the
only reason why I'd give this movie a 2/5. Once
he’s on-screen the tempo for Quantumania changes
instantly and all humor evaporates. The disparity
in quality between the wacky opening hour and the
Kang scenes are so massive to the point that if
you just isolated Kang’s scenes then this movie
becomes a 4/5. That’s why I think this movie has
such a big divide between critics and fans. Fans
will primarily focus on how awesome Kang is while
overlooking the faults the movie undoubtedly has.
Which you should just be here for Kang at the
end of the day, so if you enjoyed the movie
more than other people then that’s fine. But as an
overall package, this movie is extremely rough. I
can’t really go into detail about all the unique
writing issues because the movie isn’t out yet,
but for once I think an MCU movie has enough
problems with the script to make a devoid of
logic video. Normally there are some contrivances
and bad writing choices tied to Marvel movies,
but I think Quantumania crosses the line and
there’s just so much wrong with the script.
Going into the visual side of things, this has the
same issue as Thor: Love and Thunder where most
of the set is just the ground and everything
else is CGI. While simultaneously trying to
increase the scale the creators also strip away
the authenticity because everything feels fake.
It's hard to get immersed when the actors can
barely interact with their surroundings and it
also leads to the most bland cinematography.
Because how can the cinematographer really
get good footage when there’s almost nothing
practical on set. It basically just comes down
to the pre-vis team to deliver iconic images that
are primarily driven by CGI. This reminds me of
Star Wars again because for how much practical
elements there are within that film series,
it really makes that world feel real and
grounded. While Quantumania feels like
it's on the opposite end of that spectrum. Then
the VFX isn't as bad as everyone loves to say,
although I did spot a couple errors, but it has
some weird design choices and it's overloaded
in every single frame making each shot feel
overwhelming. One of the weird design choices
was Modok. I know he's supposed to look weird but
they shouldn't have scaled up his face by 400%
and called it a day. Looking at his comic version
in comparison to the movie version is hilarious.
For the acting and characters, the only person
here who gives a good performance is Jonathan
Majors. He deserves a lot more for hard-carrying
this movie. Everyone else though has their own
distinct issue that hinders them. Paul Rudd to me
can't carry this big dramatic baggage because of
how much comedic lines he has to keep rattling off
in every scene. Again tying back to Thor needing
to be dramatic but having a hard time fulfilling
that. Some of his moments with Kang do resonate
really well because the humor disappears and
that’s the tone the movie should of had more
of. Although that aspect of the movie would have
been better if the father and daughter bond was
stronger. For Kathryn Newton, she was never able
to excel because of how generic Cassie Lang is.
She feels like a cookie-cutter character and her
only motivation in life is to do good and help
people. So yeah, there’s not much there for her to
be that interesting and the movie quickly throws
us into the quantum realm so her introduction is
very brief. Then for Hope Van Dyne, she felt like
a background character in the movie. She doesn’t
really lead any scene for dialogue and she just
feels like she’s along for the ride. I’m surprised
the movie is called Ant-Man and the Wasp:
Quantumania because of how little she has to do
in the plot. For Hank Pym, I genuinely believe
Michael Douglas regrets joining the MCU. It feels
like he isn’t trying anymore in some scenes which
probably also has to do with the script and
making him say ants all the time, but he just
seems bored. Like there are a few moments where
the characters are in a big plain of CGI vomit
and Michael Douglas is just like yeah man, I
just don’t care about what’s happening right
now. Then Michelle Pfeiffer is supposed to be
intriguing but since the script is so contrived,
she's not allowed to tell anyone the crucial
information she holds until later in the movie.
Like if she actually opened her mouth in the
beginning then none of this would have happened.
Ant-Man Quantumania really makes you wish we
could go back to the time of Captain America
Winter Soldier because there the scripts felt so
much better. They weren't perfect by any means but
at least they weren't a jumbled mess and told
a more riveting narrative. I don't know if I'm
slowly changing and not liking the MCU anymore
because the people next to me loved it and the
theater was laughing hysterically at every joke.
To quote the people next to me: "That was fire
bro. It was fucking amazing." So yeah, everyone
has their own tastes and I’m falling on the side
of the crowd who didn’t like the movie. There
are some other massive issues I have with the
movie regarding spoilers, but if you’ve seen it
then you know. Humpty Dumpty was done dirty. But
thank you for watching and let me know what
you guys thought about Ant-Man Quantumania.